Just in order to get some more
familiarity with joint PDFs,
let us look at independent
normals.
Actually, this is an important
example because noise is often
modeled by normal random
variables, and noise terms
that show up at different
parts of a system, or at
different times, are often
assumed to be independent.
Suppose that we have two
standard normal random
variables, X and Y, with zero
means and unit variances.
If their independent, their
joint PDF is the product of
the marginal PDFs and
takes this form.
This is just the PDF of a
standard normal X and the PDF
of a standard normal Y
and we multiply them.
If we are to plot this joint
PDF we obtain this figure.
It looks like a bell which is
centered at the origin--
at the point with coordinates
zero, zero.
One way to think about what is
going on here is to rewrite
this expression as 1 over 2pi,
and then the exponential of
minus 1/2 x squared
plus y squared.
If we look at the unit circle in
xy space, which is the set
of points at which x squared
plus y squared is equal to 1,
then, on that circle, the PDF
takes a constant value because
this quantity is constant
on that circle.
And the same is true for
any other circle.
On any circle the PDF takes a
constant value, of course, a
different constant.
So the circles centered at the
origin are the so-called
contours of the joint PDF.
On each contour the joint
PDF is a constant.
Let us now generalize.
Consider two independent normal
random variables, but
with general means mu x and mu
y, and variances sigma x
squared and sigma y squared.
The joint is, again, the product
of the marginal PDFs
and, therefore, takes
this form.
This looks intimidating but, in
fact, it is pretty simple.
This part is just a normalizing
constant.
It is the constant that's needed
so that the joint PDF
integrates to 1.
What we have here is the
negative exponential of a
quadratic function of x and y.
Let us plot the contours
of this quadratic.
Remember that contour is the
set of points where the
quadratic takes a
constant value.
And by consequence,
the joint PDF also
takes a constant value.
If you have set this quadratic
to a constant, what you have
is the equation that describes
an ellipse.
And it is an ellipse whose
principal axes run along the x
and y directions, and those
ellipses are all centered at
this particular point,
mu x, mu y.
The joint PDF is largest when
the exponent is equal to zero.
And this happens when x is
equal to mu x, and y
is equal to mu y.
That is, right at the center
of the ellipse.
That's where the joint
PDF is largest.
As you move to ellipses that are
further out on this outer
ellipse, this expression
is a constant.
It's the exponential
of the negative of
some positive numbers.
So you get a smaller value
for the joint PDF.
If you move to a further ellipse
further out, then
again, the joint PDF will be a
constant, but it's going to be
a smaller constant.
Now, for the case of standard
normals, the joint PDF was
circularly symmetric.
The contours were actually
circles, instead of ellipses.
But this is not the
case in general.
For example, suppose that the
variance of Y is bigger than
the variance of X. Then you get
a shape as the one shown
in this figure.
Since the variance of Y is
larger, we expect Y to take
values over a bigger range,
and to be larger typically
than the values of X. And so
the bell shape that we have
for the joint PDF is stretched
in the y direction.
It extends further out in the
y direction than it does in
the x direction.
To conclude, the joint PDF of
two independent normals has
the shape of a bell.
The center of the bell is
determined by the means.
Furthermore, the bell is
stretched in the x and y
directions by an amount that is
determined by the variances
of x and y.
However, the stretching
is always along
the coordinate axes.
If you wanted a bell that
stretches in some diagonal
direction, or if you have
contours that are ellipses but
with some different kinds of
axes, then you will have
dependence between the
two random variables.
In that case, we will be dealing
with a so-called
bivariate normal distribution,
but we will not pursue this
any further at this point.